do you prefer traditional relationships
or a modern relationship traditional
modern
to be a man yeah yeah I don't want to
have that
um like stay-at-home wife Vibes that
have to do everything in the home and
stuff I would if he's doing what he
needs to do get in the pee bring it home
I would if we had enough to live on just
on his way to no words what would you
give up to be with a man nothing no
nothing you know what about what if he
said Instagram would you give it up I
don't even I don't want to use Instagram
yeah same but I'm all about the Facebook
life could a guy tell you what to do in
a relationship uh they have done in the
past but not going forward no same I'd
agree with what she said I'm like
certain that a man's not going to tell
me what to do